Steve has the first question,
how can we know the difference between
unhealthy repression and healthy self
restraint of sexuality?
Well,
I would say,
okay,
no part of what constitutes ethics,
let's say first of all,
let's start,
let's think about ethics to begin with.
So what's the point of
conducting your life ethically?
The answer to that isn't so that you
follow the proper rules precisely the,
the answer to that is so that you balance
your life so that it says productive
and meaningful as it can possibly be.
And that would be productive and
meaningful for you with any luck,
but also for people around
you that would even be better.
And,
and for you now and next
week and into the future.
So it's sort of a variation of the
philosopher Emmanuel counts moral dictum,
which was act such that
your action becomes a moral,
a universal,
something like that.
Although I think that it's,
it's better phrased across time
and across people like that.
Um,
so when you're thinking about an ethic
that has to do with any fundamental
motivation like sexuality,
you have to think about it in the
context of the rest of your life.
Um,
the,
the question is whether or not,
but what did I say?
What,
what did I read at one point that I
really liked with regards to sexuality?
Okay,
who's in control?
That's the issue.
Is it you or is it the sexuality that's
in control is have you integrated your
sexual life into the rest of your
life so that the whole thing makes a
harmonious balance?
And Are you in charge or is it in charge,
so to speak?
Because if you're not in charge
with that harmonious balance,
then things are going to waver wildly
out of control and you're going to find
yourself in dreadful trouble.
That happens whenever any given driver
may really any given value predominates
to the exclusion of all else.
Now,
it seems to me that sexuality is
best handled within the confines of a
relationship.
Um,
that's the classic ethical
solution to the problem.
It's because sexuality brings with it
a tremendous amount of responsibility.
Now,
people don't like to think that,
especially people who I would
say are low in conscientiousness,
let's say are high in impulsivity.
It's easy for people to believe in,
what would you call it?
Casual sex,
which is not something that I think exists
because I don't think you can divorce
sex from its sociological or
political or economic or psychological
consequences.
And I would say the endless scandals
that have plagued the United States in
particular in the last year with regards
to sexual behavior are proof that
there's no such thing as casual sex.
I think the reason for that is that the
consequences of sex are too dramatic.
It's not just pregnancy and disease,
let's say,
which are both,
um,
as dramatic as consequences
can be in life,
but also the fact that
there's no disentangling sexual
behavior from an emotional behavior.
Or maybe you could say even worse if you
try to disentangle your sexual behavior
from your emotional behavior,
then I think what happens is
that you end up cold and cynical.
I mean,
if you're,
let's say if you're a a cereal,
if you're us,
uh,
if you have a lot of one night
stands and a lot of casual partners,
then first of all,
there's not much discrimination
between one partner and the other.
And so in some sense you're in a loop
and just repeating the same act over and
over,
but you can't,
there's nothing deep about it.
There's nothing that,
that enables you to establish a
relationship with another person.
And I think that that's a,
I think that you corrupt your soul in
that way and that you hurt yourself across
time and of course you're going
to hurt other people as well.
So I'm not a big admirer
of the casual sex idea.
I think it's a demented
adolescents fantasy.
Uh,
fundamentally it just doesn't
work out in the real world.
Now,
healthy self restraint.
Well,
with regards to sexuality,
it's the same with everything
else is that there's,
there's the necessity to forego immediate
gratification for the purpose of
medium to longterm thriving,
let's say.
So if your sexualities integrated in an
ethic that encompasses the rest of your
life,
and if it serves that ethic,
then I would say it's properly restrained.
If it's unhealthily repressed,
well then you're angry and bitter and
resentful and cursing the opposite sex,
or perhaps the same sex.
If you happen to be gay for failing to
recognize your particular form of sexual,
uh,
what would you call attractiveness?
I think resentment and anger are a good
indication that there's something wrong
with the manner in which
your sexuality is restraint.
So I hope hopefully
that's a decent answer.